this wearable sensor can track the  composition of your sweat and send the  data to your phone  athletes can use information from sweat  to prevent fatigue before it starts  these four pads change color in response  to chloride glucose pH and lactate a  channel fills with sweat to gauge water  loss these indicators provide  information about hydration status and  electrolyte balance as well as the total  amount of water lost to sweat the  ability to quickly and easily monitor  these things with the phone is a huge  improvement over the previous laboratory  bound technologies the sensor is rugged  and flexible enough to move even during  strenuous exercise it may also have  medical uses in the future like tracking  blood sugar without the need to collect  blood this smart little sensor is  probably the first thing that actually  wants to be around your sweat  you